The Season 2 finale of You surprised many
fans with a shocking revelation that changed
everything for Joe and Love.
However, buried deep within the new season
is a secret second twist and hidden homicide
that only some hard-core fans have noticed.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!
I'm Jan and in this video I'm revealing evidence
of a secret murder that almost everyone missed
in the latest season of You.
There will of course be spoilers ahead, so
take care if you're not all caught up.
Season 2 surprised many viewers when they
discovered that Love is like Joe, a serial
killer with dangerously obsessive tendencies
who not only killed her family's au pair,
but also murdered Candace and Delilah.
But there's another character whose death
remains shrouded in mystery, and that's Love's
late husband James.
When Love tells Joe she became a widow, she
explains that her husband was ill, but is
vague on the details:
"He got sick.
And they, um...
they tried to figure it out.
But... they did not."
There's already something a little suspicious
about how Love mostly looks down and avoids
eye contact with Joe as she tells him this.
But in the sixth episode we get numerous flashback
scenes that reveal a lot more about Love's
dynamic with her spouse.
When she proposes to James that they try for
children, he doesn't seem keen on the idea.
And in another flashback, he argues with Love
that they can't afford to raise children without
taking money from the Quinn family which is
something they'd seemingly both agreed not
to do.
We can see from Love's reactions in these
scenes that James's reluctance to have children
with her was very painful, and that's also
something she alluded to while talking to
Joe.
"My husband hurt me, too.
Among other things, by dying."
Ever since she killed Sophia, Love has been
driven by a desire to create her own perfect
family.
"Families don't heal from something like that.
So I began to fantasize about a new one."
But when James broke Love's heart by refusing
to have children with her, I think she plotted
to get rid of him.
For example, just look how much Love relates
to Joe's reasons for killing Beck:
"Yeah, you did some terrible things but that's
what sensitive people do when they're trapped
in a bad relationship."
So, we have a motive for Love killing James,
but how did she do it?
Well, given she's a skilled chef, cooking
would be a likely way to put her plan into
action.
And as she explained, it's also a way for
her to express her feelings.
"Baking is how I express my love."
We saw how Love baked a cinnamon bun for Joe
that was made with salt rather than sugar
after she discovered he'd lied about his real
identity.
At that point Love still saw potential in
Joe as a future partner and father to her
children, so she didn't full-on poison him.
Instead, she made him a foul-tasting cake
as punishment and perhaps also a warning.
By contrast, when James ruined Love's hope
of ever creating a family together, she probably
decided to really make him pay.
And because Love already knew what it took
for Sophia's violent death to be covered up,
she may have tried to kill James in a more
subtle way that wouldn't raise as much suspicion.
If Love found a way to poison James very slowly
so that it was hard-to-detect, then it might
explain the fact that nobody ever discovered
exactly what was wrong with him.
In fact, she even referred to James detoxing
in one of the flashbacks.
"You're just detoxing."
Which could be a wellness thing or could perhaps
hint at him having a background of alcohol
or drug abuse, something which would also
provide plausible cover for his becoming sick.
And, of course, if there was any suspicion
by doctors or the authorities, then it wouldn't
be hard for the Quinns to cover it up, just
like they did with Sophia.
Love wouldn't even need to purchase any poisons
that could be traced back to her because as
a chef, as well as someone heavily involved
in the wellness industry and running a grocery
store, she could well know that the seeds
of numerous fruits like apricots, cherries
and peaches naturally contain cyanide compounds.
With Anavrin's produce and kitchen at her
disposal, Love could easily grind up small
amounts of fruit stones and blend the powder
in with James's meals to slowly administer
small quantities of cyanide that would make
him sick.
Perhaps it's even a little tell that Love
uses a peach as her introduction to Joe.
"Do you think this peach looks like a butt?"
And it's curious how Love reacts when Joe
is hesitant to eat the muffins she brings
him to eat while he's in the cage.
"Is this what you're afraid of?
No poison, Joe!"
As Joe and Love are basically a mirror image
of each other, Joe might well be thinking
of what he did to Benji or what Love did with
the salty bun, but that moment is also drawing
our attention to Love's ability to poison
her victims.
Ok, the poison theory may be plausible, but
you might ask why was Love so visibly upset
and angry at James for hiding the fact that
he knew about his illness for 8 weeks before
he told her?
Well, it's worth remembering that although
Love and Joe are both serial killers, they
each seem to react differently when killing
someone.
Joe seems to be much more dispassionate and
cold-blooded whether he's killing on purpose
or accidentally.
But each time we've seen Love murder, whether
it be Candace, Delilah or Sophia, she's been
angry and distressed.
So, even if Love knew she was the reason James
was unwell, she could be simultaneously upset
but determined to go through with the deed
because of her own warped obsession with raising
a family.
We can see this when she explains to Joe why
she killed Delilah.
"Did you actually believe I wanted to hurt
anyone?
I hated doing that to Delilah.
Was I gonna let this destroy our baby's life?
My whole life...
I've been doing what it takes...
when I love someone."
And all the way back in the first episode
of Season 2, Love makes an interesting connection
between the death of her husband and Joe.
"Ever since it happened,
I've been able to see this thing in people...
who've been through it.
I see that every time I look in your eyes."
Love later finds out that Joe killed Beck,
and if she sees the same in Joe as she does
in herself, that's a big pointer that Love
also killed the one she loved, James.
Basically, both Joe and Love fantasise about
a perfect partner or family and when their
loved one fails to fulfil that fantasy, they
kill them.
Some fans have also tried to connect Delilah's
death with James by suggesting that she'd
begun to investigate James's death along with
Henderson's.
They've pointed to the board of information
Delilah was using to write her article about
Henderson and said that there's a picture
of James on there.
Now, I've checked the scene myself, and I
can't see any such picture, only a newspaper
cutting mentioning Henderson's cancer and
a photo of him that you could say resembles
James a little.
There is a mention of a "James" on an article
to the side of that.
The article's cut off, but the title seems
like it might be about a "Film Executive."
And it talks in the past tense about a certain
"James" who appears to have worked in the
entertainment industry.
If this is Love's deceased husband James then
it's possible she met him through Forty's
attempts to break into the movie business.
So, given what Love probably did to her husband,
there's a chance she'll try to kill Joe as
well, especially if she catches him creeping
around their next-door neighbour.
Maybe she'll start slipping something into
Joe's food.
And if Joe uncovers the truth about what happened
to James, he'll very likely run for the hills.
If you've got any Season 3 theories, be sure
to leave them in the comments below.
Now, do you think Love killed her husband
James?
There's a poll for you to vote, just tap in
the top-right to cast your opinion and to
also see the results.
Next, tap left to discover all the easter
eggs and other killer details you might have
missed in Season 2 or tap right for another
video you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!